there was that stuff with Theo vaugh he
was upset like how do you deal with how
do you deal with something like that
I've never I'm happy that you brought
that up so I have never stolen any jokes
what but like how do you handle that
like I don't think that well that
particular instance I I think to myself
well I don't understand why he would
think that I I haven't stolen you know
the to catch I don't know if you guys
are aware of the context of it and I
only recently I'm aware cuz I saw a
comment that said it was just on the
internet and yeah I think he was doing
like a bar stool show and you guys both
had a similar idea in the show right he
had it in something and and then you had
he said on a shirt thing yeah it was
like a wooden shirt then you guys had in
the show I remember when we came up with
the wooden stuff in the writer's room
and it was totally built on a different
idea that was about like a one single
like a man whose entire house was made
of wood down to the clothing and then it
ended up we ended up not going with that
storyline ended up doing one small
really inconsequential scene of my
Series where a guy was just selling
wooden shirts I promise you it wasn't
I've never and I when ever I see content
of theovon online as I'm scrolling I
totally think it's funny and I respect
it I've got no animosity I've just never
met him we have so many mutual friends I
always was under the understanding that
like accusing a comedian of stealing
jokes is like a major taboo
biggest I I was like just reach out to
me and let's cuz I never and I have
nothing but respect from what I see of
his content online but I never have
stolen any joke that's really my
immediate reaction it's not like I'm not
hurt by it I'm just like why would that
why would he be so insistent that I when
I never would right right two people
can't have the same idea it's a pretty
broad idea like the idea of wooden
clothing yeah I I don't know like I'm
sure I don't know seems kind of specific
the way you just
said I'm sure not men and women are
different very onedimensional
but yeah I I I have you guys spoken at
all why don't you guys just talk why
don't yeah I I would I'm CU I think a
lot of times what would happen in these
situations is you know both sides
explain their part and then you go okay
I see why this you know these two
different comedians came to this
conclusion and it wasn't somebody that's
trying to B I'm definitely down to I
have no beef with him whatsoever I don't
like when you know if I post something
and I see like stop stealing Theo's
jokes like it's just I don't i' never
have done that yeah and I think the
there's only one joke in question it's
not like I've made like a career you
know what I mean I don't even know what
other jokes were even questioning three
seasons of Television right yeah that's
that's the thing I think like now with
the internet there are so many more
people putting things out that the
possibility of two people having a
similar idea is infinitely higher than
back in the day where there would be 10
comedy specials a year yeah and you just
need to crossover in those 10 now you
have a million pieces of content that
are out there in the world and you're
going to see people with similar ideas
you see it happen with memes you see it
happen with you know written pieces you
see all these types of things so I don't
think it like immediately means that one
person is stealing from another all I
know is that my soul feels very pure and
clean like I do I just think you guys
are both great and I would love you guys
to both just be like hey set it up
you're friends with everybody I will I
will set that up I will set that up for
you yeah I will set that up let go on
the beach and and remember if you sign
up use that promo C Schultz they will
match your initial deposit up to $100
that means you put in a 100 you get 100
for free go to prix.com